hey guys Pete here finally had a couple
of days at home which means I have a
bunch of videos I want to work on I
thought I would start off with a recap
of all the big news that's been
filtering in after the majority of the
actors for Game of Thrones were in LA
for the Emmys a couple weeks ago this
means we got little bits of news from
all the interviews they were doing but
there has been some even bigger stuff
coming out of Belfast we're shooting of
season 7 has been in full swing just a
little housekeeping before we begin I
haven't posted as much as I would like
to lately because I have picked up a
couple short-term jobs that have had me
on the road honestly it's been taking it
out of me but the good news is that I'm
doing all this now so that I can have a
few months to focus on youtube full time
so bear with me for a couple of weeks
and things will go back to normal also
the giveaway is still going on so make
sure you stick around to the end to get
details about that with all that stuff
out of the way let's get down to
business this year's Emmys were
dominated by Game of Thrones and the
show ended up with a total of twelve
wins the winds from this year helped the
show break the Emmy record for primetime
show awards that's big stuff that I
think was more interesting for fans who
already know how great the show is was
all the interviews from cast members the
biggest thing that grabbed my attention
was that when asked dave and dan said
that they wouldn't be doing another game
of thrones project after the series was
completed this isn't altogether
surprising considering the amount of
time that goes into putting a show like
this together you could tell that the
years of working on the show and time
spent away from their families and home
as them ready for a well-deserved break
luckily this doesn't mean that HBO isn't
still interested in the idea of another
game of thrones related show the
showrunner said they were out and george
RR martin deflected by saying they were
still focused on finishing games but he
mentioned that there was a wealth of
material if the network decided to
continue a week later at the west world
premiere when asked HBO's programming
president Casey boy said there are so
many properties and areas to go to for
us it's about finding the right take
with the right writer I'm going out on a
limb here to say that game of thrones
prequel series confirmed based on the
statement boy said that he would like
Dan and Dave to be involved in some way
and I really don't see them quashing an
opportunity at a chance to play a small
part in what could be HBO's next big
series I think most people would agree
that the best
s is that we will see in that apt ation
of the dunk and egg novellas since they
would transfer well into a TV series and
even though is there's still a lot of
those two right it's the same situation
where Martin knows how the story will
play out at the end even as fans we
already know that everything leads up to
the birth of Rhaegar and the tragedy of
summerhall it's really a no-brainer on a
trios far so that's all there really is
to say about that would anyone not want
to meet the female wolves of Winterfell
or a young blood raven I didn't think so
from the cast we learned how emotional
things are getting now that the end of
the series is near and got to see them
all peacocking on the red carpet sophie
Turner said that things feel different
in Belfast and that everyone is staying
around longer than they usually do
instead of flying home for the weekends
the cast is staying in town which would
explain the massive number of sightings
that are showing up on fans social media
accounts anyway that was the general
feeling for most of the interviews when
asked about the season 7 script everyone
seems to have been blown away when they
read it we already heard about this for
Maisie Williams tweet storm about a
month ago after reading the season 7
script and the other cast members echoed
the same sentiment beacon amazing one
house in LA she said this about season 7
it's going to be heartbreaking and
exciting Emilia Clarke hyped up an
upcoming battle scene saying last
season's battle was ridiculous but this
season is like there's like another
battle that's epic with Entertainment
Tonight sophie Turner said when pressed
um some crazy dragon stuff happens the
whole thing's amazing then that's all
that I can say she also said something
in relation to her and Maisy getting
matching tattoos that turned into a
story basically she said that you never
know if the characters are going to make
it through a season so they wanted to
get it done now I don't think that
confirms that either aria or Santa's
gonna die but it made some people wonder
and there were a bunch of articles about
it well all of that stuff is exciting
it's also a little bit vague let's look
at what else is coming out related to
the actual shooting of the upcoming
season in case you don't follow Watchers
on the wall which combs local sources in
Spain and Ireland for news I can tell
you that pretty much every one of your
favorite characters have been seen near
one of the filming locations Yara Theon
Brienne Sansa re
the naraz Jon Snow brand the Hound Davos
ma sandy grey worm Tyrion Cersei Jamie
Podrick Gendry little finger and so on
and so forth no surprises there really
some of the more interesting sightings
included the actors that play Robert
Glover Thoris Amir and a random kid that
showed up in pictures from the Daily
Mail what makes robot Glover interesting
is that the Glovers hold Deepwood Motte
which isn't that far from Winterfell
it's actually Northwest and situated
between what Winterfell and Bear Island
which is the home of the Mormons we saw
Lord Glover pledge fealty to Jon Snow as
the King in the north and based on their
location the Glovers could be useful and
pretty much anything John does related
to the wall or any kind of battle that
happens in the north we also got some
spoilers related to Thoros or at least
that he will be playing a larger role in
the upcoming season when we last saw him
he was with beric Dondarrion and the
Hound so we can guess that sand or has
taken them up on their plan to head
north Thoris is one of those characters
we know a little bit more about in the
books but none of what he's doing there
now as a clue to what he might do in
season 7 this is mainly because he is
still with the Brotherhood in the
Riverlands who are now following Lady
Stoneheart around barrack is actually
dead now having passed his life onto
stone heart so no clue on what the show
has in store for him this is what we
know about Thoros he's a red priest who
follows real or like Melisandre he was
actually given to the red priest by his
parents when he was young because he was
the youngest of eight children he became
a priest but seems to have been more
interested in fighting women and
drinking he was sent to King's Landing
because the red priest hoped that he
could convert king eres the second to
their cause since he was obsessed with
fire after he was unsuccessful he had a
crisis of faith he was present in court
when Tywin presented the corpses of
regards children to Robert Baratheon and
would never forget the mountains
unrestrained brutality Thoros got along
well with King Robert and became one of
his favorite drinking companions he had
a couple of other claims to fame
including being a frequent torn email a
champion he would use a sword set aflame
with wildfire to spook his opponents
horses and the Greyjoy's rebellion he
earned wrecking
in for being the first one over the wall
at pike by far as the most notable feat
was bringing beric Dondarrion back to
life Eric was killed after being
ambushed by the mountain during a burial
ritual Thoros inadvertently resurrected
him while performing the last kiss from
there they formed the Brotherhood
without banners with the purpose of
protecting the small folk from all the
soldiers roaming around in the
Riverlands bringing barrack back renewed
his faith in the red God and he finds
that he can bring him back to life
several more times he also starts to be
able to see visions in the flames other
than that we get no indication that he's
doing anything other than following Lady
Stoneheart who was on a free killing
spree since we aren't going to get the
resurrected Catlin in the show what do
we think Thoros will do beyond the
obvious of bringing himself into capable
warriors the hound and barrick up north
I think they might use him to assist
John in Melisandre absence well I don't
think we've seen the last of Melisandre
I think it's safe to say that she won't
be coming back to Winterfell anytime
soon unless maybe she comes with Arya or
something like that from shooting
reports that we know that breanne Davos
john santa pod and Littlefinger all
appear to be doing scenes together
without any mention of kris van houten
who plays the red woman John knows
firsthand about the white Walker threat
but basically no one else who is south
of the wall besides the wildlings know
how crazy the situation is Thoros would
have the same knowledge as Melisandre
and could be a helpful advisor for John
when it comes to the war for the dawn
that's my best guess but let me know
what you guys think in the comments and
then there's this kid who I was racking
my brain about when I saw the picture
this morning when I was having coffee I
saw a new video from because geek that
put forth a novel theory that hinges on
the fact that there is also a nonsense a
red-haired actress on set to break it
down simply there aren't many obvious
choices on who this young boy would be
it could be a random son of a northern
house but beyond that I really don't
have any guesses because geeks theory
goes through some not so likely choices
and then puts out the idea that maybe
he's from one of brands visions she
mentions different people he might be
none of which make a whole lot of sense
and then brings the mystery redhead and
picture the Daily Mail who's responsible
for the picture referred to the actress
as a body double for sophie Turner but
it seems like they just assumed that to
be the case the theory goes that she
could actually be a young cat limb in
one of brands visions and that the boy
could be a young little finger there's
definitely no clear evidence that this
is the case but it actually seems
plausible considering there aren't any
better guesses it could be that brand
saw little finger and saunter through
the weirwood tree that we saw them touch
at the end of season 6 and then did a
little searching into what little
fingers motivations were I'm not sure if
it's going to play out that way but it's
a cool theory so if you want to get a
better idea of how bow from because geek
got their check out the video on her
channel in filming news from Spain we
are hearing a lot about the casting of
tons of extras in my previous video
about the Greyjoy's we heard about a
battle at sea and now we're hearing
about a large seen on land by large I
mean like they hired 500 extras and
that's how many people that they hired
for the Battle of the bastards was also
said that it was going to be a battle
involving wagons but l7r learn more
saying that it might actually be
referred to as an ambush they described
a scene involving wagons with goods
traveling from a castle which would be
inserted by CGI and that gets attacked
by an enemy soldiers what's even more
interesting here is that los siete
reinos reported that that we will see at
least one Lannister involved in this
ambush because we've heard so much about
them casting people who resemble on
solid in Dothraki we can assume that
Tyrion would be there the only thing is
that the website says they have heard
rumors that the conflict with Tyrion
will involve one of his siblings as well
that could be huge since they haven't
seen him since he killed their father my
guess is that Sarah see will pretty much
not going to be anywhere except for the
red keep for the rest of her life so the
most likely candidate would be Jamie we
all know jamie has a soft spot for
Tyrion but he definitely stabbed him in
the back by killing his father after
Jamie let him go another interesting
revealed from l7r via Watchers on the
wall is that they are filming a scene
nearby that involves a major character
falling into a body of water it's
possible that this is connected to the
ambusher battle since the terrain is
similar but there's really no way to
know for sure the way the scene is
described
it almost sounds like the major
character is falling from the sky into
the water this would of course bring up
the idea that you know maybe Daenerys is
falling from drogon if she was riding
him in the action but it might also be
someone who is not quite as experienced
on a dragon since we know Tyrion will be
there we can go full tinfoil and say
that he jumps on the Syrian who lets him
ride in order to escape some sort of
attack but then loses control and ends
up in the water this would put all the
speculation to rest and confirm that he
is one of the heads of the dragon
obviously that's just a complete guess
but hey you never know I mean sooner or
later someone's going to jump onto one
of the other dragons over all those are
the most exciting bits of news there was
a report that Rhaegar was cast but in my
opinion it doesn't seem likely
apparently an American singer posted on
Instagram that he might have made an
appearance in season 7 and from there
the internet ran with the idea that he
must be John's father since there's like
a resemblance in the character it's not
confirmed either way but it'll be kind
of a disappointment to me if that was
the case since it would likely mean that
the role was pretty much insignificant
overall I'm all for some Rhaegar
flashbacks but hope to see more than a
quick glimpse that would require some
previous acting chops don't believe the
hype either way the the casting of
Rhaegar has not been confirmed that's
pretty much it um I got a couple of
other videos that I want to get out
hopefully before i go back to work i'm
working on a year on video and some
other things before i finish i wanted to
give a shout out to a new channel that
is doing some cool stuff for charity
they're called trial by trivia and
they've been doing Game of Thrones trib
you is that which is actually a lot of
fun came across their channel a couple
weeks back and had a blast answering
questions in the chat with them and all
their other followers they've also been
doing a tournament with YouTube creators
you probably know so you can watch those
episodes to see how well you would do if
you were up against them so brand new
channel and they're still growing but
the charity aspect is great and you
should check them out i'll post a link
in the description so that you can go
over there and think about supporting
the charity which train service dogs to
help people that need them please like
the video if you thought it was good and
make sure to subscribe to the channel
for a chance to win in the giveaway when
I had 18 thousand subscribers i'm giving
away a copy of night
of the Seven Kingdoms by george RR
martin all you have to do is enter and
be a subscriber and then just leave a
comment on my videos thanks for watching
I'll talk to you soon